in this video i want to give you a very
brief
overview of the history of citizenship
for
indigenous people in the united states
the story of
indigenous people in north america and
their citizenship status in the united
states
is long and complex and it's changing
even today
the supreme court recently ruled in july
2020
that indigenous people in the eastern
half of oklahoma must be tried in
federal or tribal courts not state
courts because the land
belongs to the muskogee creek nation
so i want to be clear that what we're
covering in this video is just the most
basic outline of how citizenship for
indigenous people has changed over time
there is so much more to learn on this
topic if you're interested
okay with that said let's go back to
1789
when the constitution gave the first
definition of who was
and was not a u.s citizen article one of
the constitution
mentions indigenous people twice once
to say that congress shall have the
power to regulate commerce with foreign
nations
and among the several states and with
the indian tribes
and once to say that the population of
each state as counted for the purposes
of representation
would exclude indians not taxed
that indigenous people were categorized
with foreign nations for the purposes of
regulating trade
and not counted in state populations
shows us that they were not considered
u.s citizens at that time
remember that at this time u.s
citizenship was
generally reserved for white men women
and children
and voting rights were reserved for
white men with property
the next major change in citizenship
rights was the ratification of the 14th
amendment
which guaranteed citizenship to all
persons
born or naturalized in the united states
this ensured citizenship rights for
african americans and
the children of asian immigrants but at
the time the courts did not
interpret it to include indigenous
people
only about eight percent of all
indigenous people
those who were not living among a
distinct nation
but instead within white settlements
were taxed
and therefore eligible to become
citizens now i should mention that not
all indigenous people
wanted u.s citizenship many preferred to
live separately from the united states
as part of their own nations
but as the us government and white
settlers
colonized north america rapidly in the
mid to late 19th century
they ignored the rights of indigenous
people as members of separate nations
forcibly relocating them to reservations
or even killing them in order to obtain
their land
in 1887 congress passed the dawes
act which attempted to force indigenous
people to give up their culture and
common lands
and live like euro americans on
individual tracts of
land any indigenous person who received
a land allotment would receive u.s
citizenship
it didn't grant birthright citizenship
to indigenous people
or citizenship to anyone who didn't
accept a land allotment
not until 1924
in recognition of indigenous soldiers in
world war one
did congress confer citizenship on all
indigenous people and guarantee
birthright citizenship to them with the
passage of the snyder
act which is also called the indian
citizenship
act but did having citizenship
automatically confer the right to vote
if you've been paying attention in these
videos you will know that the answer is
no many states denied voting rights to
indigenous people they faced many of the
same
barriers to accessing the ballot as
african americans did before the civil
rights movement
following world war ii indigenous people
sued for the right to vote in states
that denied them
utah was the last state to remove formal
barriers in 1962.
the voting rights act of 1965 provided
additional protections for indigenous
voters
by outlawing exclusionary practices that
deny
or abridge the right of any citizen of
the united states
to vote on account of race or color
so that's a very brief overview of
indigenous citizenship rights and voting
rights
in what ways were the citizenship rights
of indigenous peoples
similar to other minorities like african
americans
and in what ways were they different why
do you think
indigenous people may have wanted u.s
citizenship
or not wanted u.s citizenship